في مركز جباليه الطبي هنا في جباليه البلد
شمال قطاع غزه بعد ارتكاب الاحتلال عدد من
المجازر بحق عائله الشهاب وعائله جنيد
وعائله خله هناك عدد من الشهداء وعدد من
الاصابات في المكان وصلت الى مركز جبالي
الطبي وهناك عدد كبير من المفقودين لم
تتمكن الطواقم الطبيه من
الوصول اليهم هم تحت وهم تحت ركام
المنزل
كما نشاهد هنا جل الاصابات من النساء
والاطفال جراء هذا القصف من قبل طائرات
الاحتلال على المنازل بشكل
مباشر حسبنا بالله ونعم الوكيل اول حاجه
استه الاطفال والصغار وهدول مالهم ذنب
اثنين احنا فتحين ب الناس الغلاب المربه
من
المدارس يعني هذه يعنينا لله عشان الناس
الغلابه واستغلوا الموقف هذا وخبط البيت
تبعنا وبنقول حسبنا بالله واحنا بنعبي
وبنقول حسبنا بالله ونعم الوكيل يا ربعنا
هكذا المشهد الان داخل مركز جباليا الطبي
بعد القصف المتواصل على جباليا البلد
واستهداف عدد من المنازل مما ادى لوقوع
عدد كبير من من الاصابات والشهداء في
المكان يعني هو استهداف لبيوت مدنيه وايوا
للمواطنين هناك مئات شلال من الاصابات
والشهداء في هذا الصباح نحن الان خرجنا عن
كل التغطيه الخدمه الطبيه في المستشفيات
في قطاع غزه شمال قطاع غزه والان احنا
نشتغل عبر اللي هو مراكز صحيه وهذه
المراكز لا تستطيع استيعاب هذا الكم من
الشلالات والاباده الجماعيه يعني احنا
بدنا نوصي رساله
العالم الا حان الاوان تستيقظوا من نومكم
اشعر اننا جزء من هذه الانسانيه حسبنا
الله ونعم
[موسيقى]
الوكيل احنا الحمد لله رب
العالمين واللي صابنا من رب الحمد لله رب
العالمين احنا ناس امين وقاعدين في دور
الحمد لله كافيين خيرنا شرنا زي ما
بيقول لكن ربنا ربنا بلانا بش اسمه
اسرائيل اسمه وربنا عطش اكثر من هيك حسبي
الله ونعم الوكيل ايش يا
بابا ونعم الوكيل اليهود
والمشركين حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل اليهود
وال المشركين حسبي الله ونعم الوكيل حسبي
الله ونعم الوكيل حسبي الله ونعم
[موسيقى]
احنا قاعدين بن مي لاولاد ما يشربوا ما
شفنا الا هفوق
نزل كانت كنتي تحت الرخام وابن ابني هذا
تحت الرخام طلعناهم من تحت الرخام
عري والحمد لله ونطلب من الله نحتسب عند
الله
حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل كثروا الاطفال
ورمل
النساء طبعا كما نشاهد هنا منداخل مركز
جبالي اق بهذا المركز الذي لا يتسع لعدد
[موسيقى]
المصابين هو عباره عن مركز صحي صغير
لتقديم الخدمات
الاوليه منذ ساعات الفجر الاولى تم وصول
لهذا المركز عده مجازر وهذا المركز
بالامكانيات البسيطه لا يستطيع التعامل مع
مثل هذا الحجم والكم من الاصابات طبعا
المنظومه الصحيه منهاره بشكل كامل كل
دقيقه يتم فيها تعجيل وقف اطلاق النار يتم
الحكم بالحياه على عده على المئات المئات
من الجرحى والمصابين نحن هنا غارقون
بالدماء وبالعرض نحن هنا قواق الطبيه منذ
اليوم الاني لم نرى النوم على الاطلاق
الوضع كارثي جدا ماساوي جدا يجب يجب على
جميع الدول العربيه والاسلاميه وعلى جميع
دول العالم العمل على وقف اطلاق النار كما
ترون كما ترون هذه الحالات يتم تقديم لها
فقط خدمات اسعافات اوليه اسعافات اوليه
لوقف النزيف بعد ذلك لا ندري اين نذهب
بهذه الحالات لا يوجد الا هذا المركز
البسيط في شمال قطاع غزه الذي يحتوي على
قرابه 700 ال مواطن و نازح نحن هنا نتعرض
للاباده ونحن احياء اقسم بالله العلي
العظيم نموت ونحن
[موسيقى]
احياء كما شاهدتم جريمه جديده يرتكبها
الاحتلال هنا في جباليا البلد بحق عدد
كبير من العائلات مما ادى لوقوع عدد كبير
من الشهداء والاصابات وما زال هناك بعض
المفقودين انس الشريف لصالح قناه الجزيره
شمال غزه